what kind of story were you thinking
about how something in a prison oh all
right
what about
prison interests you jail
for sure
happy anniversary we're so lucky yeah so
Elliot tells me you're a writer and
you're the last one it should have done
better there's lots of new voices
refugees cancer murder abuse I'm an old
voice you're the best voice maybe if Dad
hadn't just been verbally abusive it
would have been a bestseller don't say
that
your Memoir is great your new book is
great how are you feeling a little off
my game the only reason she makes me a
salad is because she wants me to lose
weight which is passive aggressive I
want you to be healthy it doesn't matter
can you shut up and keep talking gone
you want to intervene here we can do
this at home maybe Milani looks tired
imagine what are you nuts you get BOTOX
well I just get a little bit right here
you know I can still move my eyebrows
watch watch
so expressive
oh look come on we'll go sneak up on him
can you say anything no I can't it feels
too late oh my God oh my God I think I'm
gonna throw up right here
no I don't think I can I can't
[Music]
I did say that you took it out of
context are you gonna guess like me now
an apple he's been lying to me this
whole time I wasn't lying I was
encouraging that's not true you were
lying to be encouraging you know what as
an actor Mark isn't always great so the
times when you don't think he's good
what do you send them you're so
fantastic really
Mom you're always expecting the best
from me you're welcome
[Music]
I needed to do something meaningful what
you do is is kind of meaningful to who
no one
this whole world is falling apart and
this is what's consuming you well you're
not helping
I love you
okay well never mind
[Music]
foreign